technology is ever evolving regardless
of the current market conditions
new technologies are emerging with
groundbreaking innovations to tackle
world issues
it must be strange that predictions are
being made about the future of
technology in these uncertain times
but here's the fun part these
innovations are what makes life easier
in the coming years from systems that
could predict the risk of a viral
transmission to drones that could
deliver essentials to your door
their industry is transforming our lives
so here's
a list of new technologies of 2021 that
you should watch out for
but before we begin if you love watching
tech videos subscribe to our channel and
hit that bell icon to never miss an
update at number 6 we have aerospace
technologies
the aerospace sector has countless
innovations that continue to increase
over the coming years
defense and other aerospace industries
are looking forward to building zero
fuel aircraft
new aerospace technologies include
advanced space propulsion systems
advances in material sciences smart
automation
and blockchain with the help of 3d
printing many aerospace components are
being developed
given the global situation although
innovation in this field may come at a
calculated pace
it is likely consistent at number 5 we
have 5g networks
with an increase in video conferencing
remote working and digital collaboration
this year
reliable connectivity and better
bandwidth are crucial
5g deployment is preventing companies
from going out of business
as we continue to manage school and work
from home 5g will play a key role in
2021
companies like samsung apple and xiaomi
are readily rolling out 5g phones
qualcomm arguably the leader in 5g
technology is helping make 5g affordable
to as many smartphone users as possible
next year
reports say that the global 5g services
market is estimated to reach 41.48
billion by 2020
and expanded an annual growth of 43.9
percent from 2021 to 2027.
at number four there's edge computing
almost all technology in today's world
are applications of edge computing
collaborations with artificial
intelligence 5g and mobile cloud edge
will make data processing closer to the
customers
leading to faster and more efficient
computing even amidst the pandemic
companies continue to consolidate and
expand their offering of edge solutions
from traditional rugged embedded
computers to high performance edges for
ai
and other data intensive applications
according to experts
the edge analytics market is expected to
grow up to eight billion dollars usd by
2021
at a cagr of 32.6 from 2016 to 2021 at
number three
we have extended reality extended
reality includes augmented and virtual
reality
this technology in conjunction with
others will be used during the next year
to tackle challenges posed by the
current situation
it will largely help in avoiding
dangerous situations that could
potentially cause a viral transmission
over the coming years this technology
will revolutionize healthcare
education and lifestyle among others the
ar and vr market revenue is expected to
reach 55 billion usd by
2021 at number two there's human
augmentation
with the principles of exceeding
replicating and supplementing human
ability
human augmentation changes what it means
to be human
the augmentation pipeline holds other
great promises for the future
like bionic human joints embedded
scanning
customizable contact lens augmented
skull
feet artificial windpipes for your
throat etc
the possibilities are endless the global
human augmentation market is predicted
to rise at a considerable rate
during the forecast period between 2020
and 2026
but most of the innovations today are
being facilitated by
one vital technology can you take a
guess as to which one is made to the top
of the list
that's correct at number one we have
artificial
intelligence artificial intelligence or
ai has proven to be one of today's most
transformative tech evolutions
however with the current world scenario
artificial intelligence seems more
promising than ever
the volume of data collected on
healthcare and infection rates can be
used
to prevent infection spread in the
coming days machine learning algorithms
will be increasingly sophisticated in
the solutions they uncover
in the coming year ai will make
predictions on demand from hospitals and
other healthcare providers
according to experts global spending on
cognitive and ai systems will reach 57.6
billion in 2021
and the ar market will grow to a 190
billion dollar industry by
2025. with that being said if you wish
to create something cool and help make a
difference
check out simply learn's postgraduate
program in ai
and machine learning in partnership with
purdue university
and in collaboration with ibm it covers
topics like machine learning
deep learning statistics and nlp among
others
in conclusion with such big advancements
in technology
the future looks more promising than
ever it is likely to reshape all sectors
of life
there's simply no stopping it have you
heard about new innovations that have
been recently implemented
let us know in the comments section
below thank you for being here and watch
out for more videos from us
until then keep learning and stay tuned
to simply learn